Jyn, quoi que je fasse...
Je le fais pour te protéger.
Tu le sais.
Oui, je le sais.
Tu veux sortir d'ici ?
Notre rébellion, c'est tout ce qu'il reste pour faire reculer l'Empire.
Nous pensons que tu peux nous aider.
Quand as-tu vu ton père pour la dernière fois ?
C'est quoi, ces questions ?
Il semblerait qu'il joue un rôle capital dans la mise en œuvre d'une arme surpuissante.
Si c'est mon père qui l'a conçue,
il faut qu'on le retrouve.
D'accord ! De combien d'hommes on a besoin ?
Ils demandent un nom de code !
C'est...
Rogue.
Rogue One.
La force de frappe dont il est question...
est sans limite.
Si l'Empire dispose d'une telle puissance de feu,
quelles chances nous reste-t-il ?
Il nous reste l'espoir.
L'espoir est la base de la rébellion !
Ils ne s'attendent pas à nous voir.
Vivez pleinement ce moment !
La Force est puissante !
Dix hommes leur paraîtront une centaine.
On saisira la première occasion.
Et la suivante.
Vous êtes des rebelles, non ?
Sauve la rébellion !
Sauve notre rêve !